[Música]
piden mejores salarios y condiciones
laborales lo que empujó a algunos
actores a unirse por solidaridad
enfrascados en una disputa con los
estudios cinematográficos creo que la
pelea es real creo que han pateado el
avispero estoy listo para caminar por el
tiempo que sea necesario para obtener un
contrato justo el sindicato de actores
de la pantalla federación estadounidense
de artistas de radio y televisión que
representa a 160.000 actores está de
acuerdo con los escritores dicen que las
cadenas no han compartido la riqueza
ambas profesiones exigen mejores
salarios pero también restricciones en
el uso de la Inteligencia artificial en
las producciones la huelga de guionistas
ha hecho que los programas de
entrevistas nocturnos se repitan sin fin
así como la producción de televisión
interrumpida además de algunas películas
de Gran presupuesto con los actores
podría haber aún más retrasos o incluso
cancelaciones
francamente los actores son más
poderosos colectivamente que los
escritores por ejemplo vas a ver una
película porque tu estrella favorita
está en ella las estrellas de Hollywood
Nicole Kidman y Zoe Saldaña dijeron que
esperaban un resultado rápido y justo de
la disputa de los escritores
Solo espero que pase lo que pase sea con
el propósito de llegar a soluciones
rápidamente para que la gente pueda
volver a trabajar
personajes destacados como Jennifer
Lawrence y Marilyn Streep dijeron
previamente que estaba en listas para
pausar su trabajo